Hong Kong's government is attempting to
pass a law that would for the first time
allow extradition to mainland China the
proposal is cause massive opposition and
a series of protests riot police have
used tear gas and rubber bullets on the
demonstrators still the administration
is pressing ahead the bill was proposed
by the government in February
it covers mainland China and other
jurisdictions that could include Taiwan
it was sparked by the case of a Hong
Kong man accused of murdering his
girlfriend in Taiwan he was arrested in
Hong Kong and convicted of
money-laundering but couldn't be sent
back to Taiwan for trial because there's
no legal framework to do so the
government said the new law will make
sure Hong Kong doesn't become a haven
for fugitives but opponents are
concerned that it could open the door
for anyone including political
dissidents or civil rights activists who
might risk being arrested on fabricated
charges in Hong Kong and sent to the
mainland to face unfair trials apart
from Hong Kong citizens the law would
also apply to foreign residents and even
people passing through on business or as
tourists it's one of the latest moves
under Chinese President Xi Jinping that
is viewed as chipping away at Hong
Kong's autonomy which guarantees free
speech and capitalist markets this time
protesters are hoping to repeat the
success of a demonstration in 2003 which
led the city to scrap a national
security law and contributed to the
resignation of the then chief executive
but it might also end up like the
umbrella movement in 2014 which failed
to achieve universal suffrage after
student-led protests occupied city
streets for 79 days
you